having seven income streams to become a
millionaire is BS and I'm gonna show you
why in 60 seconds so let's say this is
you and this is your time and attention
that you have to pursue any new
opportunity so you say I need seven
income streams because the average
millionaire has seven income streams so
I'm going to spread myself thin between
seven different opportunities and I'm
gonna wait until one of these things
takes off but the reality is is not
which of these ones will work any of
them could work if you put the work in
it's absolutely true the people who are
the wealthiest have multiple income
streams but what's not true is about how
they got there the wealthiest people in
the world go all in on one income stream
and they keep adding it up over and over
and over again until it overflows they
then start diversifying back between the
other different ways but they made their
wealth focusing on one thing and then
they maintain their wealth by
Distributing it you don't make money by
splitting your attention up you make it
by focusing on the one thing that
matters most